our kids get very grossed out by us in
general they are sickened by us
and i'm not sure why that is
kelly ripa and mark consuelo say their
kids are totally grossed out by them
and reveal the um
unique way they hold hands
watch this everyone
so
this is how we hold hands
the riverdale star guest hosted live
with kelly and ryan on monday and the
love birds who share three kiddos 24
year old michael 20 year old lola and 19
year old joaquin admitted that their
kids are completely repulsed by their
not so polite table manners our kids get
very grossed out by us in general but
especially when we're eating they are
sickened by us
and i'm not sure why that is
but they are disgusted by our eating
they make fun of my eating a lot
yes have you noticed that well you're
very yeah you have a very interesting
way of eating food
yeah kelly may not understand why her
kids are so grossed out but mark
he seems to know what's up
well you eat normal food normally with
but every now and then if there's
something that could be
uh used with your fingers you'll go in
and you'll
first of all you put the plate in front
of me and then you'll go in and grab it
and then you stick you stick all three
fingers the tips of all three fingers
into your mouth
like that
of course this is hardly the first time
kelly and mark's offspring have rolled
their eyes when it comes to their mom
and dad yeah this is what happens when
you meet during a screen test and you
fall in love you have a love child no we
didn't have a love child we were married
first that's true
last year the 51 year old daytime tv
host posted this sexy swimsuit selfie
with her hubby checking out her backside
with his mouth wide open in awe
she's beautiful
the caption quote when the end is in
sight
get it and is in sight like her rear end
is in his sight
you get it he is incredible shortly
after that their youngest son stopped by
his famous mom's show and called her out
live on air how do you feel about the
pictures of mommy and daddy when she
posts them oh man um
look it's
the one recently where it was the
what do you mean
you know you know what i mean yeah we
all know what he means oh my gosh i
don't even want to think about it in our
family everything is left unsaid
mark and kelly's love goes way back and
they tied the knot in 1996.
i'm the luckiest woman in america
more than two decades later and they
still know how to keep things hot i
would say marriage is a blessing
yeah and keeping the romance and pda
alive
it's not always easy
we just tried something we never do at
home but for some reason we tried it
backstage
holding hands
which as you know
we are arm length incompatible
on monday kelly said they go to great
lengths literally to hold hands this is
how we hold hands
so we have to hold hands like this yeah
this is how we walk and hold hands i'm
not kidding that is how we walk and hold
hands it's all right you know what in
new york people are like yo take up the
whole sidewalk and i go have you seen
our arms shut ass
go around us
you know what they say it doesn't matter
how long your arms are when you're
laying down
did it just get like 10 degrees hotter
in here of course the pair knows how to
make us blush and they did just that
back in 2019 when they joked about
counting down the days until their kids
moved out of their family home to go off
to college
i'm truly going to be running through
the house naked i just want everybody to
know that
i'm going to be sitting on every piece
of furniture naked be warned before you
come over
that's what i'll be doing in my spare
time
and you're welcome america
[Music]